Ragnarok is finally upon us God of War
Ragnarok that is PlayStation's biggest
game of the year as well as the end of
the God of War Norse mythology duology
is here and as an ending it's fitting
that the game takes its name from
Ragnarok the name for the Norse
apocalypse and the end of everything in
our Cosmos including the very Gods
themselves Ragnarok is one of the
defining events of Norse mythology as it
really is the culmination of the entire
tale of the Acer aka the Norse gods and
everything around them it's a battle
where the fates will decide the final
end of everyone big and small so let's
become gods of lore as we take a look at
the actual story of Ragnarok in Norse
myth how it is similar and different to
what we've already seen in God of War
2018 and what it all might mean for
kratos's ultimate fate
thank you
the word Ragnarok in Old Norse myth
translates to fate of the gods or
Twilight of the Gods and fate it is
because not a lot of gods survived this
one which is probably why so many fear
it Odin the all-father perhaps most of
all as he is always attempting to avert
the end this matches up with what we
hear about Odin in God of War 2018. as
we see his Ravens constantly watching
Kratos and atreus as he seemingly knows
that they might have something to do
with the coming of the end this is
because there are telltale signs that
Ragnarok is coming signs that the gods
themselves try to stop happening in
order to avert the end times one of the
biggest signs was the death of balder
the son of Odin and Freya in myth Freya
was so worried about the fated death of
her son she went to every single living
being in the universe to make them
magically swear to never hurt Boulder
ensuring his safety however Loki being
the trickster that he is learned that
Freya hadn't bothered to ask mistletoe
to swear an oath about balder Loki then
for fun decided to then trick the god
halder to throw a mistletoe Spirit
balder as holder thought that he
wouldn't be able to hurt balder because
of his oath that didn't really end well
for balder who died shortly after our
spear was chucked into him and thus one
of these signs of Ragnarok came to pass
and if you want to know more about that
story about the death of balder I
actually went into it in further detail
in our other video in the series on
Loki's history I'm going to stop here
and say big spoiler for God of War 2018
but getting back to Ragnarok though God
of War 2018 is clearly distinct from
Norse myth when it comes to balder but
there are certain Echoes of that story
father is that game's Chief antagonist
hunting down Kratos because he thinks he
is a yoten guardian who has been
bothering the Acer turns out here balder
is Immortal so no matter how many times
Kratos kills him he just keeps coming
back like the Leviathan ax
when Odin sent me here I just needed
answers but you
you had to act all proud throw whatever
you have
been coming that old body will get out
but before I end this
I want you to know one thing
I can't feel any of this turns out Freya
in this version of the story Put a Spell
on him to prevent his faded quote
needless death making him invulnerable
to all threats sadly though this spell
also left balder unable to feel anything
drinking women
it's all gone
to feel pain again death has no power
over you now you would rather die
yes
take it away I can't please please
please take it away it doesn't
like that
eventually though father's hand is
pierced by a mistletoe Arrow by atreus
kratos's son and this freed Boulder of
his curse and he was immediately then
killed by Kratos because the big guy has
to earn his God killer status now if the
mistletoe arrows didn't clue you in we
learn at the end of the game that atreus
is actually Loki himself a fact that
atreus and even Kratos to a degree don't
fully understand or comprehend but means
a hell of a lot to us especially
considering Loki's place in Norse myth
the Giants called me
Loki
Loki
unto the name your mother wanted for you
when you were born back in Norse
mythology in retaliation for killing
balder the Acer chained Loki underground
where a serpent endlessly drips Venom on
his forehead only stopped by Loki's wife
catching it in a bowl yet Loki was also
not the only person put in Chains the
gods also tricked one of Loki's children
the wolf fenrir into chains by
pretending it was a test of the wolf's
strength because fenrir himself was also
fated to wreak havoc throughout the nine
Realms leading to Ragnarok all this
though is a seeming departure from God
of War as it seems at least from the
trailers that we can tell like atreus
isn't in chains for having killed balder
but he may be at some point in the story
though it is worth saying being bound in
Chains certainly has a resonance with
kratos's chains of Olympus a punishment
that was bound to his flesh by the Greek
gods of old
once attached the chains remained so
Chained and seared to the flesh a part
of the bearer's body a permanent
reminder of kratos's pledge in return
ultimate power in fact we even meet the
world serpent German gown in God of War
2018 who is also technically Loki's
child in Norse myth yet something that
does line up with God of War 2018 is the
first sign that Ragnarok is soon to be
upon us the coming of thimblewinter a
great winter that will cover the nine
Realms which we actually see beginning
at the very end of God of War 2018. bit
of a cold snap lately what he means is
Thimble winners upon us boys the winner
to end all winners this winter shall
last three years and Mankind during it
will become so desperate that they will
struggle to survive and all of
civilization will crumble even more so
though jigdrasil the great tree of the
cosmos that we see Kratos using the
bifrost within to Traverse the nine
Realms will also begin to tremble in
fact in myth the great tree will tremble
so much that it will free Loki and
fenrir from their chains fenrir will
then run across the Earth eating the
ground and the sky as his brother
jorming gound will rise from the oceans
spilling the sea onto the land and
spitting Venom all over the world Loki
himself will take charge of an army of
the fire Giants of misbelheim and march
across the bifrost to face the Gods in
Asgard on the Rainbow Bridge a horn will
blast out blown by Heimdall himself to
announce the moment of Ragnarok has come
Odin fearful will seek the head of the
wisest being mamir for advice and guess
who has mimir's head in God of War are
PAL Kratos and we do know that Odin will
appear in God of War Ragnarok now we are
obviously in wide speculation territory
here but you did get to visit misbelheim
in God of War 2018 in the game's trials
and it's already been announced that we
will visit all the Realms in God of War
Ragnarok including Asgard itself which
was gated off in the first game who's to
say young atreus won't be getting fire
giant allies this time as he heads into
Asgard yet Odin and myth does eventually
decide to go to war with Loki Odin will
eventually fight fenrir during the
battle who will swallow Odin hole Odin's
son Vidar will avenge his father's death
by killing the wolf Loki himself will
fight Heimdall with both of them ending
up killing each other as well as Thor
and Norman gound who have hated each
other for Millennia Thor will end up
killing the serpent with his hammer but
the serpent himself will have covered
the Thunder God in so much venom that he
will not survive so the quest remains
where does Kratos fit in the battle will
he take someone's place in the myth or
will his very presence change the
outcome another prophecy no brother
prophecy doesn't expect this from 100
more winters at least you've changed
something prophecy didn't count on you
yet there is still a bigger question at
Play
what happens after Ragnarok one version
of the story has Ragnarok literally
destroying everything nothing will be
left except a giant void and perhaps an
end credit screen another version of the
tale holds that a few Gods might
actually survive but more importantly a
single normal man and woman named leaf
and Lee thrisser will find themselves
surrounded by A Land Reborn a lush
verdant field under a single tree if all
of that sounds familiar well it should
Christians who encountered the
Scandinavians worshiping the Acer wanted
to convert them to the Christian faith
so instead of trying to say that their
gods didn't exist these Christians
argued that instead of Ragnarok coming
it had actually already happened and was
actually a prequel of sorts to the Old
Testament that this was actually the
garden of Eden's story and that leaf and
lethar were actually Adam and Eve and
that the new ruler was the Christian God
so by doing this the Christians created
a new mythology built on top of the
ashes of the old one while the morality
of centuries-old Christians trying to
subsume and control other cultures is
outside the realm of this video's
discussion it does leave interesting
questions for God of War Ragnarok
because while we're all excited for this
game the question does come up well
what's next we know that Ragnarok is
supposed to be the end of the Norse
duology but will that be the end of
Kratos and atreus somehow I doubt it
considering how well these games sell
for Sony so if Kratos and or atreus
survive where will they go now that most
of the Norse pantheon might end up dead
like the Greek gods before them at
kratos's hands while I doubt Sony Santa
Monica will be so bold as to make the
next game Kratos vs Jesus they could
easily use the destruction at the end of
Ragnarok to move our heroes into a new
Pantheon of mythology there's already
precedent for it in history yet this
leads us to reflect on what Ragnarok
itself means to many vikings who
believed in Ragnarok the twofold nature
of the stories ending was part of the
point it was a story of both tragedy and
rebirth tragedy in the sense that all
things die even the memory of this world
will eventually be gone along with the
gods themselves a sense of doomerism
that all struggle is pointless in the
end
Vikings saw it as a chance at New Life
to create something new that we can
believe that something can always be
built on the ashes of what came before
and that the inevitability of death
should not cause us to despair but
always hope for more and this perhaps
lies most at the core of the tale of
Kratos and atreus Kratos is a man who
has always seen the world in anilistic
light that nothing mattered not even
himself given all the tragedy that he's
faced throughout his life one could
understand and yet he is given hope
through his son a chance at rebirth
something new perhaps Kratos passing on
a new world for his son mirrors the
meaning of Ragnarok itself but only time
will tell once God of War Ragnarok
finally arrives to Signal the end of
this story but there's still so much
more to talk about when it comes to God
of War so if you like this video check
out our other videos in the god of lore
series and you can also find more of our
coverage about God of War right here on
Gamespot so don't forget to subscribe
subscribe to make sure you don't miss
any of it
[Music]
[Music]